what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
leaving earth and transitioning to the
andromeda galaxy
this place was home to a rich tapestry
of races and histories at least until
the scrolls rose to power while their
early history remains largely ambiguous
what we do know is that some 1 billion
years ago the scroll world of screwloose
was visited by the Celestials taking
place prior to their experiments on
humanity the task followed the same form
and functioned gather a handful of the
primitive scroll race and modify their
genes but unlike early humanity this saw
the rise of four groups instead of three
the baseline Scrolls with a potential
for future mutations the deviant scrolls
the eternal scrolls and finally the dire
wraiths governed by narcissism in
geocentrism the deviants found
themselves able to shape-shift and came
to view themselves as the perfect form
of their race on the other hand the vast
cosmic energies of the eternal Scrolls
led to a life of peace with no true
concerns for the goings-on of their own
planet existing as something akin to the
Morlock in the Eloi Queen slew Gert
convinced the deviance that they alone
were the rightful heirs to the mantle of
the scroll race considering all others
to be beneath them Scylla Gert and her
soldiers attacked the eternal Scrolls
annihilating all but one convincing
Slugger to spare his life kleben
revealed the truth to the deviance that
by the actions of the Celestials they
had imposed upon them a half-life that
with each new generation their
shape-shifting abilities would give rise
to future mutation which would go
unchecked and eventually push their race
into extinction
however the eternal scroll stood
unchanging an immortal living tributes
to the greatness of what would one day
become the scroll Empire speaking of a
future where their race would stretch
into the Stars
kleben convinced lagar to spare his life
and in doing so transcended themselves
into godhood creating the foundation of
the scroll central religion the pantheon
and the book of worlds where this
newfound pact came with the fall of the
eternal Scrolls the dire wraiths were on
the march themselves were driven and
without mercy the dire wraiths instilled
a fear within the deviance that they had
never known
possessing powers of sorcery it was
believed by the deviance that should the
dire race make their move and attack the
deviant scrolls themselves would be
totally destroyed taking to the
offensive the deviant scrolls marshaled
their forces across the planet from
every large city and every small village
outnumbered by an estimated ratio of
1,000 to one the dire race fled scroll
O's taking up residence in the Dark
Nebula with no one left to challenge
their dominance over scroll O's the
scroll race spent the next 500,000
millennia evolving and changing looking
to the holy texts of the book of worlds
the scrolls intended to bring about
their prophesized future of conquering
the andromeda galaxy by expanding
outward in every conceivable direction
thus the development of interstellar
travel and enhanced weapons saw the
scrolls spreading to distant worlds
killing nearly every member of every
race they encountered the gods of haeth
omen maker path lighter drew fanned
rious were among the many to fall to the
power of the scrolls and were in turn
used as propaganda their desecrated
remains spread among the halls of
worship as a testament to the power of
the scrolls themselves and their own
pantheon of gods by 10 million BC the
scroll race had left behind their days
of war now the unrivaled rulers of the
Andromeda galaxy their lack of need for
war gave way to a more peaceful Age of
Exploration led by emperor Doric the
first the throne world had been moved
from scroll owes to tarnex for
recognizing to the power of the far-off
Shiar Empire resided in their
conscription of races instead of their
wholesale slaughter Doric sought to
bring other races from other galaxies
into the fold visiting the planet Hollow
and the greater man jalena cloud the
scrolls found the planet home to two
races the Cree and the Cotati
primitive as they were the scrolls took
a handful of each race left him on the
oxygen-rich blue area of our smooth and
provided them with a year's worth of
supplies and resources looking to test
each race a returning in one year
surveying how the scroll technology was
used arriving at the experiments end
Doric looked upon the works of both
races and to his dismay the Cree had
built a massive technological city while
the Cotati
had built a lush and vast forest finding
the cotati more in line with her
peaceful views the scrolls judged
against the Cree considering them to be
unworthy angered at this verdict and in
a twist of irony the Cree delegation
slaughtered in pure Doric and his entire
scroll delegation as well as the co
toddy on the moon reverse engineering
the scroll technology the Cree traveled
back to their homeworld slaughtered what
remained of the code haughty and began
their war against the scrolls using
their newfound understanding of
interstellar travel the Cree built vast
fleets of warships and invaded crawl
space conquering world after world in a
blitzkrieg of galactic proportions
seeing all they built seemingly vanished
before their eyes the Saviour of the
scrolls came in the form of a single
negligent Cree warrior sent by the
Supreme intelligence who stood as both a
spiritual and political leader of Cree
society this single soldier was tasked
with acquiring the crystal of ultimate
vision an eye omnipotent artifact that
allowed for vast reality manipulations
however where the origin of the crystal
is unknown those seeking to capture it
must pass a test resting on a pedestal
on the far side of the universe in the
Citadel of light and shadow the crystal
will tempt its capture with wonderful
visions of absolute power giving them
control over the very fundamental forces
of the universe those who were foolish
enough to reach for that of greed would
find themselves failures and their
entire race cast into evolutionary
stagnation unable to evolve as the
universe passed them by but for those
who reached for it out of virtue they
will be granted its full power intending
to secure the crystal as a means to not
only eliminate the scrolls but seize
control of the entire universe the Cree
were deemed failures and
frozen and their evolutionary state
realizing the breaking free from this
curse superseded all others the supreme
intelligence recall decree war fleets to
Hollow initiated the universal and human
project and began the establishment of
the accuser Corps
you
[Music]
so as the ages continued on new
Emperor's rose to replace the old the
kree-skrull war was cooling off and by
10,000 BC the Scrolls had long returned
to the role of explorers with the
Unconquered space of the universe
growing smaller owing to the continued
expansion of the Shiar the Badoon in the
Cree the scrolls look to expand beyond
their own universe and explore other
dimensions ordering his science castle
to initiate the singularity project this
rift in space-time released energy which
was confined in a stasis cube analyzing
its power while the scrolls remain
blissfully unaware that they had
successfully managed to breach to beyond
vers the home of the white lures of wild
space what they did not know was that
the power contained within this cube was
capable of reshaping reality itself
ordering the artifact to be brought to
his chambers the unknown emperor of the
scroll Empire became obsessed constantly
talking to the cube prising it above
even his own Empire
however the cube itself began to grow
adopting the traits of the now mad
emperor and in doing so christened
itself the shaper of worlds annihilated
2/3 of the Andromeda galaxy's population
and took off to the stars
setting the scroll development back
millions of years and returning them to
a barbarous state
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
you